tenait à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat la commission des
finances du sénat a demandé récemment à
la cour des comptes une enquête sur le
mode de financement du cnc le centre
national de la cinématographie
or son constat est sans appel le cnc
évoluent dans un environnement
budgétaire dépourvu de toute forme de
contrainte c'est donc tout le système de
financement de la création audiovisuelle
et cinématographique en france qu'il
faut repenser je vous propose donc ce
matin de suivre l'audition du président
du cnc mais aussi des membres de la cour
des comptes qui ont réalisé cette
enquête par la commission des finances
du sénat bonne matinée à tous mesdames
et messieurs mes chers collègues nous
allons pouvoir entamer cette audition
qui je le crois est une audition de
l'audition attendue et qui est fait
suite à différents travaux menés dans le
passé par la commission des finances du
sénat puis à une enquête réalisée par la
cour des comptes
à notre demande ou titre de l'article 58
2 de la loi organique sur les lois de
finances alors c'est une audition et qui
est ouverte à nos collègues de la
commission de la culture nous nous
réjouissons de les accueillir
autour de la présidente de cette
commission
marie christine blandin est de notre
côté prendront activement pas à la
discussion
le rapporteur général bien sûr et le co
rapporteur spécial de la mission culture
des crédits de la mission culture aymeri
de montesquiou l'enquète
que nous a remise la cour des comptes
concerne donc la gestion et le
financement du cnc ou en toutes lettres
le centre national du cinéma et de
l'image animée
c'est un sujet sensible car il s'agit
d'un domaine d'excellence d'une grande
industrie participant à notre
spécificité nationale mais en même temps
il s'agit d'un bon sujet de politique
budgétaire
c'est un cas d'école en quelque sorte un
cas d'école mais qui est petit lustré et
le phénomène que je qualifiais il ya
déjà hélas un certain nombre d'années
d'ailleurs sans succès d'agents 6 à sion
de l'état cette tendance de l'état a
confié des politiques régaliennes ou
leurs prolongements à des entités
établissements publics en particulier
financée par des ressources affectées
mais
il s'agit du développement des
opérateurs et et les les collègues ici
présence souviennent et des initiatives
qu'il a fallu prendre au fil des années
pour tâcher de ne contenir cette
évolution et pour appliquer à la gestion
des opérateurs les mêmes règles autant
que possible en matière d'effectifs de
dépenses de fonctionnement de dépenses
d'intervention et qu'au sein des
services centraux de l'état a eu même et
notre notre commission avait donc
empiriquement et mis le doigt
sur un certain nombre de questions qui
sont à présent reprises de manière
beaucoup plus rationnel est organisée
par la cour des comptes
mais je souligne la la continuité de nos
travaux et sur le cnc et travaux animé
par les rapporteurs spéciaux et travaux
animé par les rapporteurs généraux
successifs
et puisque et c'est un sujet que je
mettais efforcé à l'époque de 2,2
commencé à débroussailler et nicole
bricq avait poursuivi ce travail
j'observe d'ailleurs que dans le projet
de loi de finances pour 2013 qui nous
est soumis figure un article 28 qui
reprend une idée que j'avais formulée
et tandis que l'article 26 du même
projet de loi de finances revient sur le
dispositif de plafonnement adopté en loi
de finances pour 2012
naturellement parmi nos questions
figurent celle de savoir si les 150
millions d'euros dont il s'agit
d'écrêtement des ressources du cnc sont
bien calculer et s'il ne serait pas
concevable
ici nous sommes à la commission des
finances à la commission de la culture
exprimera son point de vue nous nous
avons nous aurons tendance à nous
demander s'il n'est pas possible d'aller
un peu plus loin mais je ne voudrais pas
préjuger du contenu de cette audition
je remercie particulièrement le
président de la troisième chambre
patrick le phare les rapporteurs de la
cour
antoine maury et blandine
sorgues et le contre rapporteur monsieur
jacques tournier puisque la cour
respecte avec scrupule et son
organisation et ses procédure collégiale
au titre du centre national de la
cinématographie nous nous réjouissons de
recevoir le président eric garandeau
et nous savons combien est importante de
son action pour le développement et le
rayonnement de notre industrie
cinématographique se sont même si nous
abordons et les sujets dont il s'agit et
sous un angle comment dire
sous un angle budgétaire bon je ne vais
pas le qualifier
nous ne sous-estimons pas valeur de ce
qui est fait au sein de cet
établissement
bien au contraire mais bon il ne faut
pas nous en vouloir
n'est ce pas exercer les missions pour
lesquelles nous avons bénéficié de la
confiance de nos collègues et le
ministère de la culture est
naturellement là puisque représenté par
christopher mille secrétaire général
adjoint puisqu'il y à des euro ne vont
pas nous recouvrement entre les les
les activités de l'administration
centrale et celle du cnc nous y nous y
viendrons tout à l'heure la direction du
budget et est représenté par le
sous-directeur de la 8ème sous-direction
alexandre grosse part le chef du bureau
de la justice et des médias puisque
alexandre tisserand donc l'un en
direction du budget fait coexister la
justice et les médias tout pourquoi pas
et quant à la direction de la
législation fiscale
arnaud magnin sous directeur de la
fiscalité des transactions
la représenter la part d'eads et des
recettes affectées des différents
prélèvements de nature fiscale et est
évidemment essentiel dans le débat que
nous allons avoir dans un premier temps
je vais demander au président le fin et
de synthétiser en une dizaine de minutes
s'il le veut bien
les travaux de la courge sait bien que
ce temps de parole est très frustrant
mais mais mais mais notre audition sera
rendue d'autant plus interactive et ceci
et permettra aux différents collègues de
s'exprimer s'ils le souhaitent
et puis bien entendu le président le fin
et les membres de la délégation de la
cour et ré interviendront sur la base
des questions qui seront formulées ou en
fonction de nos besoins d'information
surtout qu'ils n'hésitent pas à le faire
après cette intervention liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes
ensuite cela va de soi et le président
garandeau et sa tutelle ministérielle et
bénéficieront comme il est naturel
dudu du droit de réponse est
je souhaiterais pour ma part que le
dialogue puisse se nouer entre la cour
le sénat le cnc et sur trois principales
questions que je me permets de formuler
en achevant cette intervention liminaire
première question quel serait le bon
niveau de prélèvement sur les ressources
ou sur le fond de roulement ou sur les
deux du cnc sans fragiliser et les
missions de ce dernier dont groupe
s'établit la limite raisonnable
deuxièmement le modèle économique du cnc
qui a pour principale conséquence
d'inciter l'opérateur a programmé des
dépenses de manière à utiliser la
totalité de ces ressources et ce modèle
économique est il question de portée
générale question un peu doctrinal est
il compatible avec la situation actuelle
des finances publiques 20 peut-il y
avoir une exception culturelle qui est
soit à ce point différent des des usages
des règles dont la direction du budget
et le le gardien vigilant sans coeur
sans âme comme sa mission le suppose
naturellement
et puis troisième question et que penser
des relations entre le ministère de
tutelle et le cnc et la prospérité
relative donc je mets cela entre
guillemets et du centre national a pu
conduire la cour nous le dira a
externalisé vers cet opérateur certaines
dépenses budgétaires qui n'entrent plus
dans
les enveloppes du ministère mais que le
ministère a su mais jusque là en quelque
sorte
et y'a t'il bien eu une stratégie
d'évitement de la norme de dépense
applicables au budget du ministère de la
culture au sein du budget de l'état ou
enfin en d'autres termes et les uns et
les autres ne sauce ne se sont ils pas
opportunément rendu service
et ensuite longues
pardonnez-moi le caractère direct de ces
questions mais ce sont les les
principaux sujets vue de notre côté et
donc la cour les les
les interlocuteurs et du cnc et du
ministère de la culture
le cas échéant les remarques
complémentaires de l'administration de
bercy puis le rapporteur spécial le
rapporteur général la président de la
commission de la culture
le rapporteur jean-pierre leleux que
j'ai vu tout à l'heure
aie aie aie aie aie à partir de là notre
discussion va pouvoir s'organiser bon
nous avons prévu pour ce pour cette
audition une durée approximative de deux
heures comme nous le faisons
habituellement
enfin au terme du débat nous aurons à
prendre une décision sur la publication
de l'enquète de la cour dans le cadre
d'un rapport d'information et vous ayant
dit tout cela je donne la parole au
président patrick le merci beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
l'anc est que la commission des finances
a commandé à la cour et dont j'ai
l'honneur de présenter les résultats
visait en accord avec votre rapporteur
d'une part à porter un jugement sur
l'efficacité et l'efficience de la
gestion du
sans compte national du cinéma et de
lits et de l'image animée dans sa
mission de soutien aux filières
cinématographiques et audiovisuelles et
d'autre part à apprécier la situation
financière de l'établissement et la
pertinence de son modèle de financement
et les trois questions posées par le
président vont évidemment servir de fil
directeur à mon intervention ce choix de
denquête je dois dire s'est avéré
prémonitoire puisque la matière traitée
est au coeur de l'actualité
l'enquète s'inscrit en effet tout
d'abord dans le contexte très porteur du
cinéma français chacun a en tête
elle fait aussi écho à une réflexion
engagée sur les agences de l'état le
président vient d'y faire allusion en
particulier une phrase du rapport de
l'inspection générale des finances
méritent d'être cités celui ci souligne
que les taxes affectées aux opérateurs
qui représentent près de 10 milliards
d'euros soit près de 20 % des apports
financiers totaux de l'état aux
opérateurs soulèvent d'importantes
difficultés de gouvernance est d'ordre
budgétaire le 3e troisième raison du
caractère prémonitoire de cette de cette
enquête c'est que elle inclut en
arrière-plan toute la réflexion sur les
outils l'adaptation des outils de
l'exception culturelle à l'ère numérique
qui a été confiée à monsieur pierre
lescure
elle ne peut d'autre part ignorer les
incertitudes juridiques concernant la
conformité au droit communautaire de la
taxe sur les distributeurs de service de
télévision qui alimentent les caisses de
l'état taxe qui va faire l'objet d'une
enquête par la commission européenne
et de ce point de vue des indications
données par la ministre déléguée montre
que
le gouvernement réfléchirait à une
adaptation de cette taxe sous la forme
d'un prélèvement forfaitaire sur chaque
abonnement fixe ou mobile mobile
intégrant une offre de télévision
ce qu'on appelle la tnt 2 enfin les
conclusions de cette enquête vient à
point nommé puisque vous vous saisirez
dans quelques semaines après l'assemblée
nationale du projet de loi de finances
pour 2013 à titre liminaire je tiens à
saluer tout au long de l'enquète la
disponibilité des services du cnc et
aussi de d administration de tutelle
ministère des finances inclus et puisque
les rapporteurs ici présents honte
toujours trouvé une écoute extrêmement
attentive et réactive alors à leurs
questions et la contradiction s'est
déroulée je pense dans des conditions
tout à fait tout à fait sereine
je tiens aussi à dire que la réforme
budgétaire et comptable de grande
ampleur qui a été mise en oeuvre par
l'établissement et ceci à la demande du
précédent contrôle de la cour est une
vraie avancée et a permis de disposer de
données financières très précise même si
on peut regretter qu'on ne soit pas allé
au bout c'est à dire jusqu'à la mise en
place d'une comptabilité analytique
le rapport étudie successivement les
ressources du cnc les aides déployés par
l'établissement
il analyse ensuite gestion interne et
propose des pistes pour en améliorer le
pilotage
il met enfin en évidence la nécessité de
redéfinir le modèle de financement du
cnc le niveau de ses ressources
actuelles n'apparaissant plus corrélé à
ses besoins structurels la cour formule
14 recommandations et identifie trois
scénarios alternatifs sur lesquels nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir alors
depuis la création du cnc en 1946
l'extension des missions de
l'établissement et la multiplication des
taxes qui lui ont été affectés ont
conduit à sousse très progressivement la
politique cinématographique et
audiovisuel du champ des dépenses du
budget général de l'état
chan qui constituent la norme pour la
conduite des politiques publiques et
bien sûr de toutes les politiques
culturelles et donc à laisser s'accroît
de manière ininterrompue les ressources
et les dépenses publiques consacrées au
financement des secteurs soutenus par le
cinéma cette évolution a été rendue
possible par le système des taxes
affectées
ceux-ci qui permettait
d'échapper aux règles fixées en matière
de normes de dépenses pour le pilotage
de la dépense du budget général
le principe général commandant cette
construction militaire original est le
suivant on taxe les la diffusion des
contenus cinématographiques et
audiovisuelles et on n'en reversent le
produit un organisme qui finance
l'ensemble de la filière au nom de son
principe ont été successivement taxer la
billetterie des salles de cinéma les
chaînes de télévisions les sociétés
vendant ou louant des contenus
audiovisuels sous forme de vidéogrammes
et en dernier lieu
les distributeurs de service de
télévision cette notion large regroupant
des opérateurs aussi divers que les
chaînes de télévision acheminé par un
décodeur les opérateurs du câble
les fournisseurs d'accès à internet et
les opérateurs de téléphonie mobile au
cours de la période sous revue
le rendement de ces taxes a crû de
manière très sensible les ressources du
cnc son passé ainsi de 528 millions
d'euros en 2007 à 867 millions d'euros
en 2011 soit une augmentation de 46 3%
qui est inédite chez les 80 opérateurs
les 80 autres opérateurs du ministère de
la culture la communication
ceci évidemment lié au dynamisme des
recettes affectées des taxes affectées
qui représentent plus de 90% des
ressources de l'établissement puisque
comme vous le voyez sur ce graphique
le produit des taxes affectées a
progressé de 442 millions d'euros
de 2001 à 2011 où il atteint 806
millions d'euros la création en 2007 de
la taxe sur les distributeurs de service
de télévision
la tst distributeur a joué un rôle
majeur dans l'augmentation des
ressources de l'établissement
le produit de cette taxe passant de 94
millions d'euros en 2008 à 322 millions
d'euros en 2011 au point de représenter
près de 40% des recettes du cnc
bénéficiant de cette forte progression
de recettes
le cnc a développé ses aides au secteur
cinématographique et audiovisuelle comme
vous pouvez le constater sur cette
diapositive le montant de ces aides qui
s'élevait à 468 millions de
en 2007 a atteint en 2011 575 millions
d'euros soit une progression là aussi
inédites parmi les politiques publiques
de la mission culture de 23 % en quatre
ans diverses nouvelle z ont vu le jour
axé davantage sur les supports de
diffusion que sur les contenus comme
c'était le cas dans la logique
traditionnelle de soutien à la
production un vaste plan de numérisation
dont je pense que nous aurons l'occasion
de reparler des salles et des oeuvres a
par ailleurs été engagés sur la période
2010-2015 représentant au total près de
372 millions d'euros pour accompagner
l'adoption de cette nouvelle technologie
de diffusion par les différents maillons
de la chaîne du cinéma
cette multiplication de dispositifs
reflète une économie générale des aides
dans laquelle la création de nouveaux
mécanismes ne s'accompagne pas de la
nécessaire évaluation de la cohérence
globale des soutiens les dispositifs
s'empilent on en compte 66 en 2002 la
mesure de l'efficacité des aides peine
encore à se faire une place dans un tel
cas relents sauf à accepter sans
discussion le postulat selon lequel le
dynamisme d'un secteur emporte la
nécessité de lui affecter toujours plus
d'argent public et donc d'en faire une
priorité de politique publique de rang
daron supérieure à toutes les autres
priorités gouvernementales
la justification d'une telle
augmentation continue des aides n'est
pas clairement établie à cet égard sans
s'être livré à une évaluation exhaustive
des aides du cnc parce que le temps nous
manquer la cour souhaite néanmoins telle
attention sur la nécessité de croiser
plusieurs indicateurs pour apprécier le
dynamisme de la filière
cinématographique et audiovisuelle ainsi
l'augmentation du nombre de films
produits chaque année
204 en 2000 à 2 172 en 2011 c'est à dire
une hausse de 33% qui apparaît comme un
objectif sous jacent de la politique de
soutien déployés par le cnc ne saurait
représenter à lui seul un motif de
satisfaction car cette politique de
soutien que j'aurais tendance à
qualifier quelque peu de quelque peu
productiviste a pour contrepartie une
exposition de plus en plus limitées dans
les halles
l'évaluation des résultats atteints par
rapport aux objectifs doit également
conduire à s'interroger sur la
pertinence de certains dispositifs dead
dès lors qu'il représente par rapport
aux objectifs des résultats stables
voire déclinant pour des coûts souvent
croissant c'est le cas en particulier
dans le domaine audiovisuel où la france
entretient un système d' aide unique en
europe dans son principe et dans son
ampleur
229 millions d'euros en 2011 pour des
résultats d'audience des productions
nationales parmi les plus faibles du
continent
dans ce contexte même s'il y avait
vraiment ici ou là de très brillant
d'exception dans ce contexte la cour
recommande d'élaborer une méthode
d'analysé de l'efficacité et de
l'efficience des dispositifs d'être
mises en oeuvre au regard d'une part des
autres soutiens et d'autre part des
objectifs fixés au cnc par ses tutelles
et par le parlement sur le plan de la
gestion interne c'est un des points que
vous avez évoqué monsieur le président
le contrôle menée par la cour conduit à
constater des progrès par rapport au
précédent contrôle en matière de
transparence des coûts de fonctionnement
mais nous relevons que le prélèvement
sur le produit des taxes affectées pour
financer les frais de gestion du cnc
augmentent plus vite que ce même produit
plus 72 % contre plus de 60 pour cent
entre 2007 et 2011 nous observons aussi
que la masse salariale croit deux fois
plus vite que les aides versées et que
les dépenses d'indemnisation des membres
des commissions dead sélective du sénat
connaissent une forte progression
il n'y a pas de schémas pluriannuels de
stratégie immobilière
enfin malgré l'aisance delà de sa
trésorerie le cncr emprunter 22 millions
d'euros pour financer l'acquisition de
l'immeuble du 3 rue galilée
ce qui évidemment est venu augmenter la
dette publique alors même que elle
disposait d'une trésorerie qui
malheureusement parce que les critères
de maastricht y résonne en brut et non
pas en es tu faisais que notre dette
publique ensemble administrations
publiques augmentaient certes de 22
millions d'euros mais c'est tout de même
ça mérite réflexion
au delà de l'augmentation des aides à
court terme l'examen des recettes et des
dépenses de l'établissement met en
oeuvre des marges de manoeuvre
jetair incontestable le fonds de
roulement et c'est aussi un des points
que vous avez évoquées qui s'élevait à
800 millions d'euros au 1er janvier 2012
doit certes permettre d'honorer les
engagements ce sont les provisions mais
aussi les crédits à reporter donc il n'y
a pas de débat là dessus mais au delà il
y a d'incontestables marge de
redéploiement des réserves budgétaires
qui sont libres d'affectation et je
pense que notre débat permettra d'y voir
plus clair en tout cas il ya trois
usages danser dans ses réserves le
financement du vaste plan numérisation
des films et des salles 250 millions
d'euros
la constitution d'une réserve destiné à
prévenir les retournements de
conjoncture 57 millions d'euros
enfin le financement du plan immobilier
d'établissements 28 millions d'euros
ceci en vue de regrouper l'ensemble des
quatre immeubles sur un site unique dans
paris
si la mise en oeuvre en réserve témoigne
d'un principe de prudence qui n'est pas
critiquable en soi
elle invite néanmoins à s'interroger sur
l'adéquation entre les ressources de
l'établissement et ses besoins internes
favorisés par l'autonomie à la fois
budgétaire grâce aux taxes affectées et
institutionnels de l'opérateur alors je
rappelle que ça gêne à l'établissement
public dont le président n'a pas de
lettre de mission qui n'est pas lié avec
le ministère de la culture par un
contrat de performance qui échappent
quasiment en totalité à la justification
au premier euro et qu'il ne dispose d'un
conseil d'administration que depuis 2009
le modèle de financement du cnc conduit
en effet à déterminer le niveau des
dépenses et vous l'avez dit en fonction
du montant des recettes issues du
produit des taxes la pérennité de ce
modèle se trouve à l'évidence
aujourd'hui remise en cause par la
situation globale des finances publiques
et je pense que là aussi nous devons
nous poser la question de savoir si à
cet effort de redressement des comptes
publics
le cnc ne doit pas apporté son écot et
qu'elle en est l'importance
le liquidateur a lui-même pris la mesure
du problème donc ce sont les systèmes de
prélèvement exceptionnel sur le fond de
roulement d'écrêtement du produit de la
taxe
vous avez rappelé les dispositions que
vous aurez à examiner sur
le prélèvement en contrepartie de la fin
de l'écrêtement est donc ce que ces
points là mérite évidemment d'être pris
en considération pour la cour ces
dispositifs ne semble pas pouvoir
constituer une orientation durable et
jean qui terminerait par là permettant
de maîtriser de manière fine
l'adéquation entre les recettes et les
dépenses de l'établissement sur le long
terme
et ceci pour trois raisons la première
c'est que l'assiette de la taxe sur les
distributeurs de service de télévision
n'est pas sécurisé et la pérennité de
cette taxe est aujourd'hui conditionnée
à l'examen de sa nouvelle assiette par
la commission européenne et les
indications que nous avons c'est que une
enquête formelle va être déclenchée dans
les prochains jours ou prochaines en
tout cas prochaines semaines et donc ça
crée évidemment un élément de
d'incertitudes sur la pertinence du
modèle de pilotage autonome par la
recette
deuxièmement est toujours au sujet de la
teste et distributeurs la cour considère
que le lien entre le fait générateur de
la taxation à savoir l'activité de
distribution de contenus numériques
relevant de catégorie extrêmement
diverses l'assiette de la taxe c'est à
dire le chiffre d'affaires résultant des
abonnements aux services de
communications électroniques et son
objet le financement de la création
cinématographique et audiovisuelle
apparaître à bien des égards beaucoup
plus distendus que pour les autres taxes
notamment la magie de la tess à et de la
tnt éditeurs troisièmement les
mécanismes correctifs instauré en loi de
finances depuis deux ans ne résulte pas
d'une analyse fine des besoins de
financement analyse au demeurant entravé
par l'architecturé complexe du
dispositif des aides du cnc et par
l'insuffisance de la démarche de
justification au premier euro
présentés dans les documents budgétaires
la question qui se pose donc à vous à la
représentation nationale mais si une
question qui interpelle la cour est la
suivante quels sont les moyens envisagés
pour permettre au cnt de poursuivre une
action ambitieuse personne de doute que
l'oeuvre accomplie
ne doit pas être ébranlé en matière de
soutien aux industries 6 mai au secteur
aux filières également cinématographique
et audiovisuelle sans présenter les
recettes d'une taxe ayant vocation à
frapper un ensemble bien plus large que
la seule distribution de contenus
audiovisuels et sans se soustraire aux
arbitrages budgétaires pour la cour la
réponse consiste à privilégier une
approche qui aboutissent à subordonner
le niveau de la recette asnières et
archi dation préalable est aussi précise
que possible des besoins du cnc rendue
nécessaire par l'exercice de ses
missions
parce qu'elle ne saurait produire ses
pleins effets sans une implication
accrue du ministère de la culture et du
parlement dans la détermination de ses
orientations stratégiques comme du
niveau de ses interventions
cette évolution requiert au minimum que
l'établissement enrichissent ces outils
d'information et que le levier de son
pilotage soit également renforcé et
c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
présentons les trois scénarios le
premier c'est donc la fixation d'un
plafond de dépenses pluriannuels
commandant la détermination du barème
des textes affectées au cnc
le deuxième c'est le recours à des
écrêtements ciblé proches de la
situation actuelle ce scénario en
différé néanmoins par le caractère ciblé
des écrêtements si ce mécanisme prévost
enfin la budgétisation donc le troisième
scénario la budgétisation d'une partie
de l'actuelle tester distributeurs celle
frappant les opérateurs de
communications électroniques l'issue du
contentieux communautaire relative à la
taxation des opérateurs de
communications électroniques
un sujet évidemment plus large que le
sujet du cnc et les choix qui seront
exprimés par le ministère de la culture
et de la communication et par le
parlement quant à l'intensité
souhaitable de maîtrise des dépenses du
cnc pourrait conduire à privilégier l'un
ou l'autre de ces scénarios
en définitive les différentes
recommandations formulées par la cour
vis tout un même but assurer le
déploiement d'une politique performante
de soutien au cinéma lieu de visuels
disposant d'une visibilité sur ses
moyens et rendons des comptes sur leur
utilisation
merci monsieur prix
monsieur le président le phare si je ne
me trompe vous avez dû utiliser un petit
quart d'heure 1
donc je voudrais demander à présent à
monsieur le président garandeau et le
cas échéant à la tutelle culture et à la
tutelle finances de bien vouloir
s'exprimer en réponse pour la même durée
c'est-à-dire un petit quart d'heure si
vous le voulez bien
bon avant que bien entendu les questions
ne fuse et ne vous conduisent à
reprendre la parole monsieur le
président car en deux messieurs
président je vous remercie ainsi que
pour la salle temps de parole je
voudrais tout d'abord évidemment vous
vous remercier pour votre attention
constante à l'égard des des politiques
publiques du financement de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma
et puis aussi tout mettre en vedette une
en exergue une phrase du rapport de la
cour des comptes qui a qui a retenu
toute notre attention
la gestion du centre demeure mal connue
alors même que le cnc à de brillantes
réussites à faire valoir et pour nous
c'est une remarque vraiment intéressante
parce qu'elle pointe une forme de
paradoxe c'est à dire que nous avons
parfois l'impression que notre modèle et
notre brillante réussite sont finalement
mieux connu à l'étranger qu'en france et
nous voyons tous sommes enviés copié
dans le dans le monde entier que parfois
notre modèle suscite finalement le plus
d'interrogations dans notre propre pays
je vais laisser donner quelques exemples
de cela c'est que demain par exemple
nous recevons monsieur youssou ndour qui
est ministre de la culture du sénégal et
qui veut mettre en place au sénégal un
cnc sur le modèle français après avoir
vu que le cnc marocain qui était
lui-même fondé sur le système français
avait permis au maroc finalement de
retirer totalement son épingle du jeu en
matière de cinéma
nous avons eu également des visites
aussitôt après la révolution tunisienne
du gouvernement tunisien et nous sommes
en train de travailler avec le
gouvernement tunisien à mettre en place
un cnc en tunisie sur le même principe
que je vais décrire ce n'est pas un
hasard non plus il ne voyons souvent la
ministre de la culture du brésil qui a
créé un cnc également fondé sur une taxe
prélevée sur la téléphonie mobile et qui
va générer plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars dans l'est dans le
cinéma brésilien
on peut multiplier les exemples la corée
du sud on connaît son cinéma
extraordinairement dynamique
a eu un prix à la mostra c'est
d'ailleurs le seul grand festival
européen de cette année où la france
n'ait pas eu le grand prix est bien ou
encore et il y a ce qu'on appelle le
coffee qui est un cn s'est construit sur
la base du modèle français
on pourrait ainsi multiplier les
exemples sur tous les continents et rien
que les semaines passent et les
philippines la mongolie le bhoutan pas
tous les grands pays qui veulent miser
sur leur industrie audiovisuelle parce
qu'il voit bien que c'est l'industrie la
plus dynamique une des plus dynamiques
de l'économie mondiale eh bien tous à
l'exception évidemment des états unis
qui ont leurs spécificités et qui ont
une position ultra dominante mais tous
regardés modèle français y compris la
chine continentale qui ne comprend pas
comment la france sans quotas sur les
films américains réussi à avoir une part
de marché de 40% de ces films nous avons
des échanges quasiment mensuel avec la
chine
donc tous ces exemples montrent qu
évidemment notre modèle intéresse je ne
vois pas évidemment résumé la réussite
française au cnc mais il est vrai que le
cnc est présent je dirais aux trois
angles de ce qui forme une forme de
triangle magique qui ait le soutien au
film et il faut vraiment produire
suffisamment de films en quantité pour
que la qualité soit là et qu'elle puisse
correspondre aux goûts de tous les
publics
le soutien apporté aux salles de cinéma
s'il n'y a pas de grandes salles de
belles salles un réseau suffisamment
mallié sur le territoire eh bien il n'y
a pas de non plus de réussite possible
il faut soutenir les salles et puis le
public le public français est un des
plus éduqués du monde n'y a qu'en france
où des films iraniens ou des films de
vraiment de tous les pays y compris les
plus petits et les plus spécifiques
reçoivent à un tel succès est d'ailleurs
ces cinéastes comme asghar farhadi je
suis tel un film iranien viennent
s'installer en france ensuite pour faire
leur film et ses cinéastes ont des
oscars alors pourquoi ce succès en fait
nous avons une règle qui est vraiment au
coeur de ce qui vient d'être indiqué à
l'instant par leur part rapport de la
cour des comptes qui est pour nous
vraiment la règle d'or
et c'est cette règle qui est transposé
aussi à l'étranger
c'est que finalement laval doit financer
lamont la distribution doit financer la
création
c'est la seule façon vous parliez
d'exception culturelle je répare une
exception économique la seule façon de
résister à l'hégémonie du modèle
américain
c'est de pouvoir construire une
alternative avec un sou
un public important qui est celui du cnc
qui est aussi celui des chaînes de
télévision de leurs obligations
d'investissement et comme l'a montré
récemment le rapport de marc tessier sur
la télévision connectée
le changement majeur à qui est aussi et
probablement aussi important par plus
important que celui de l'invention de
l'imprimerie la révolution numérique ait
conduit à semble-t-il est semble-t-il à
l'auteur aux auteurs de ce rapport à
renforcer la position du cnc puisque les
autres soutiens traditionnels vont avoir
tendance à s'éroder et à s'infléchir ce
que nous avons en france est un modèle
en fait départ forcé en quelque sorte
qui permet de réinvestir dans la
création mais aussi la distribution la
diffusion et l'exportation de ressources
prélevées en aval sur une filière encore
une fois qui est dominé par un marché
dominant qui est le marché le marché
américain aujourd'hui peut-être de
d'autres nationalités à l'avenir ce lien
est d'autant plus fort que l'essentiel
des aides 60% dans le cinéma et 80% dans
l'audiovisuel sont des aides automatique
donc vous avez ce phénomène verte qui ne
coûte rien au budget de l'état puisque
ça a été remarquée même on a même pris
des dépenses à notre à notre chat à la
charge du cnc et je voudrais donc
maintenant après cet aperçu très
générale rentrer un peu plus dans
quelques sujets un peu plus précis tout
d'abord rappelé comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs que la cour des comptes a pu
valider et salué les réformes qui ont
été engagées par le centre du cinéma
depuis 2004 qui était la date de son
précédent rapport
donc la réforme budgétaire et comptable
a permis d'accroître la clarté et la
sincérité des comptes mais également la
sécurité financière de désengagement du
centre et ça c'est évidemment important
de le mentionner parce que c'est ce qui
est à la source de l'augmentation
importante de notre volume de trésorerie
l'essentiel une trésorerie est consacrée
à la proue provisionnement en fait des
soutiens générer et de toutes nos dettes
qui sont destinés à être investis à tout
moment peut être dans un an peut-être
dans dix ans s'agissant des salles de
cinéma donc c'est vraiment cette
sécurisation
cette démarche très prudentielles qui a
conduit à augmenter très fortement le
niveau de notre trésorerie
la réforme fiscale aussi a été salué
avec le transfert au cnc des opérations
de recouvrement et de contrôle fiscal
des principales taxes affectées qui sont
désormais réaliser à moindre coût comme
ç'avait été remarquée aussi dans le
rapport de la mission d'enquêté de
contrôle du parlement une réforme de la
gestion des personnels
ils sont désormais couverts par un
statut d'agent public en bonne et due
forme la réforme de la gouvernance et du
cadre de l'action du cnc cela a été
rappelé également avec la modernisation
de la réglementation du secteur la
création du code du cinéma et de l'image
animée
et puis la création du conseil
d'administration qui est outre nos
tutelles allez les représentants des
administrations de l'état du ministre de
la culture et des finances est
aujourd'hui même de l'éducation
nationale nous avons aussi des
magistrats un nombre de la cour des
comptes de la cour de cassation des
représentants du personnel est désormais
de représentants du parlement
un deuxième point qui concerne un
chantier qui est qui est devant nous
c'est la chambre le chantier du contrôle
de gestion et de la performance des
aides alors je dirais que nous avons une
succession d'audit externe et de
contrôle externe depuis 18 mois parce
que nous avons eu cinq audit
l'inspection des finances de les
affaires culturelles et la cour des
comptes la mecque et puis aussi des
audits ponctuelle de la commission
européenne donc tout ça n'a pas permis
de développer entièrement notre chantier
de de comptabilité analytique et de
contrôle de gestion mais c'est en effet
bien entendu notre principale priorité
en matière de gestion c'est donc de
construire cet outil de comptabilité
analytique
je voudrais ensuite revenir sur ce qui a
été indiqué sur la performance ce que je
citais un peu en introduction il faut
vraiment voir que cette performance en
matière de cinéma d'arts je crois que
vous le disiez vous même monsieur le
président l est effectivement reconnu et
elle est on ne peut plus visible mais il
faut bien voir que c'est la conséquence
de l'approfondissement de ceux de ce
mécanisme donc initié en 1948 avec la
taxe sur les salles de cinéma transposé
sur les chaînes de télévision dans les
années 80 81 86 et étendu en 2007 dans
le dans le champ des nouveaux réseaux et
au nom de la neutralité fiscale et
technologique et au nom de cette règle
que plus le nombre de canaux de
diffusion augmente plus le volume
d'heures demandé en termes de programme
qu'il s'agisse de films de cinéma ou de
programmes audiovisuels plus ce volume
augmente plus évidemment il faut fournir
à ce secteur et c'est ce que permet avec
vraiment une grande vertu ce modèle les
taxes affectées qui doivent donc
demeurer proportionnelle aux à
l'évolution de ce chiffre d'affaires
global du secteur audiovisuel
c'est un point important parce qu'on a
tendance à se focaliser sur
la période la plus récente où il ya eu
un rattrapage d'un retard en réalité qui
existait dans la progression du compte
mais la cour des comptes a fait un
travail à juste titre de faim en tout
cas très intéressant de vraiment des
analyses sur très longue période et a
mis en évidence quand entre 1988 et 2000
le budget du cnc est passé de 224
millions d'euros à 480 millions d'euros
c'est à dire qu'il augmentait de 114%
serre qui l'a beaucoup plus augmenté
dans la décennie précédente que dans la
décennie il juste immédiate dans le même
temps il faut voir que la laque ou la
console à les dépenses des ménages ont
pour m audio visuelle avait augmenté de
135 % entre 10 88 et 2000 et qu'ils ont
également augmenté de 116 % entre 2001
et 2011
donc le cnc qui augmente et 60% autour
de la même période
en réalité il a augmenté moins vite que
sous la période précédente et donc ce
rattrapage qui a été fait grâce à la
réforme introduite en 2007 a permis de
combler ce retard et de faire face par
ailleurs à un mouvement qui est
totalement exceptionnel mais qui est
malheureusement ou heureusement durable
qui est cette révolution numérique qui
conduit à bouleverser l'ensemble du
champ audiovisuel et à démultiplier
évidemment le le nombre de programmes
accessibles par le consommateur le
consommateur dont la durée de
consommation évidemment a augmenté
également au fil du temps donc il est
vrai je pourrais entrer dans les détails
sur les indicateurs mais je crois que
vous les avez tous en tête sur notamment
sur le cinéma mais sur le diesel je
voudrais insister sur sur la question de
notre performance en matière
audiovisuelle
elle est certes un peu moins
exceptionnel qu'en matière de cinéma
parce qu'en matière de cinéma j'aurais
quand même dire qu'on se réfère souvent
l'allemagne la performance de la france
est bien meilleure que celle de tous les
autres pays y compris l'allemagne qui
parfois utilisée comme point de
référence puisque la part de marché
allemande et de moitié inférieure à la
part de marché française et c'est aussi
lié au nombre de films produits parce
que la france produit 207 films
d'initiative française contre 132 film
pour l'allemagne donc c'est important en
matière de cinéma regardez une
proportion entre le nombre de films
produits en france et le nombre de films
diffusés en france et on en produit 200
7 et 270 si on prend les minoritaires
sur un nombre de films sortis en salle
de 600 donc cette part de 35%
elle nous permet d'avoir une part de
marché équivalente et qui est même
supérieur c'est-à-dire que nous
surperformons
le site les films internationaux y
compris et concret américain et en
comparant avec ce qui se passe dans le
reste du monde et le reste de l'europe
on voit que ne serait ce qu'au si
l'effondrement de la fréquentation en
italie en espagne au portugal le la
france finalement non seulement réussi à
faire de mieux en mieux on prend part de
marché en fréquentation mais réussit
aussi en parla le très grand nombre de
coproductions a généré une économie en
utilisant recours envoyé en soutenant
les grands cinéastes de toute l'europe
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que l'ensemble
des cnc européens aujourd'hui et est
derrière la france dans son combat
vis-à-vis de la commission européenne
pour que notre la taxe qui a été ajustée
par le parlement l'année dernière que
cet ajustement qui visait à récupérer un
opérateur dont vous aviez d'ailleurs je
me souviens aussi dénoncé le
comportement d'optimisation pour ne pas
dire d'évasion fiscale cet ajustement
fiscal et aujourd'hui il est
effectivement bloqué depuis un an à
bruxelles mais nous ne désespérons
absolument pas le premier ministre est
intervenu sur le sujet auprès de
monsieur barroso donc nous ne
désespérons absolument pas de voir ce
sujet réglé très prochainement
c'est vraiment pour l'intégrité de ce
modèle absolument essentiel puisque la
neutralité fiscale et technologique elle
doit fonctionner jusqu'au bout dès lors
qu'on régule un secteur il faut le
réguler jusqu'au bout sinon c'est le
gars qui parle de problèmes que peut
avoir sur les paradis fiscaux ou des
bailleurs ou qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les paradis numériques
donc je voulais juste me faire aussi un
retour sur la sur l'audiovisuel nos
performances en réalité sur l'animation
est exceptionnel aussi on s'en sort à
peu près dix longs métrages d'animation
par ans ceci c'est assez unique au monde
y'a que les coréens les japonais qui est
évidemment les américains qu'ils peuvent
en faire autant
nos parts de marché augmentent je
voudrais dire le montant enfin de la
progression du chiffre d'affaires à
l'exportation de nos programmes
audiovisuels c'est + 13 % en 2011 c'est
dans une économie française très
déprimée exportations de nos programmes
audiovisuels + 13 % ça c'est assez
remarquable
alors il n'y a rien à faire une
fragilité qui demeure qui essaient de la
fiction française
effectivement c'est à 6 et une anomalie
la fiction française était moins
performante ces dernières années sur nos
écrans de télévision que les fictions
américaines
il ya deux raisons à cela d'une part les
diffuseurs privés notamment ont fait le
choix d'acheter des programmes
américains sur étagère parce qu'ils
coûtaient moins chers et donc ils ont
dit qu'ils avaient le meilleur
la fiction américaine qui était déjà
amortis sur son marché principal et ce
qui permettait dans une logique
immédiate de court terme d'avoir des
audiences effectivement satisfaisante et
qui d'ailleurs habitués ensuite le
public à des programmes d'excellente
qualité sap a été le choix des 18,2 des
diffuseurs dans les autres pays qui ont
privilégié leurs fictions nationales et
ça c'est donc ça c'est la première
facteur d'explication c'est le choix des
diffuseurs une logique de court terme
est par ailleurs il faut remarquer que
le cnc a moins investi en proportion sur
la fiction française qui nous l'a fait
sur les autres genres et également sur
le cinéma
pourquoi tout simplement parce que l'ag
d'hier et les diffuseurs investi c'est
quand même des moyens importants dans la
fiction mais ce qui compte 10 via la
formater un peu plus aussi et par
ailleurs nous avions des besoins très
importants en matière de documentaire et
l'animation
donc la solution en réalité ce qui a été
très bien montré par le directeur
général du groupe canal+ qui a lui-même
engagé une nouvelle stratégie regarde la
fiction c'est en fait d'augmenter tout
simplement les moyens qui sont alloués à
la fiction que ce soient les moyens du
cnc loup et évidemment les moyens des
diffuseurs puisque là encore le cnc
n'intervient qu'en deuxième rang c'est
le diffuseur comme qui apporte
l'essentiel du budget et de la décision
en matière audiovisuelle donc voilà la
solution pour la fiction c'est plutôt
d'investir davantage
rodolphe belmer a rappelé qu' un épisode
d'une série américaine ça coûte 2
millions $ en france on est plutôt à
700000 euros et donc il faut pouvoir
augmenter pour être plus performant et
quand on le fait ça marche et on réussit
même à exporter nos formats aux
américains et aux anglais
donc c'est absolument pas de fatalité
voilà je crois que j'ai peut-être été un
peu long mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est vraiment le modèle de l' agence
qui était évoquée comme une agence
moi ça me rappelle le rapport de jean
picq qui avait nourri mes études de
sciences po le rapport de jean pitié
prenait une modernisation de l'état en
développant les agences est ce qu'on
peut remarquer dans le champ culturel
c'est que vous prenez le cnc la
politique du cinéma vous prenez le
louvre et la politique des musées
nous sommes numéro un et numéro deux du
monde donc est-ce que l' agence est un
gage de modernité de gestion et de
meilleures performances économiques
nous avons la faiblesse de le penser en
tout cas c'est vrai pour le secteur
culturel
je remercie merci monsieur le président
est
je vais à présent demander aux
représentants de la tutelle culture et
finance de bien vouloir s'exprimer
brièvement je prendrai un exemple en
lait en les interpellant le fait pour un
établissement public placé sous leur
tutelle et bénéficiant d'une trésorerie
significative de s'endetter à hauteur
d'une vingtaine de millions d'euros pour
acheter un immeuble rue galilée nom est
ce que c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont vu
est ce qu'ils se sont prononcés est-ce
qu'ils ont approuvées
je sais bien que ce n'est qu'un exemple
mais pour nous aider à comprendre si la
tutelle est présente et à quel point
elle est présente
il pourrait être utile que de part et
d'autre on veuille bien nous répondre et
je demanderais aussi à la tutelle de
s'exprimer sur les provisions et car
nous comprenons bien que comme dans une
entreprise on provisions des risques
maintenant et le fiscaliste qui arrivent
et qui regarde les comptes de
l'entreprise s'interroge sur la réalité
des risques pour savoir si la provision
est déductible ou non est ici c'est un
peu la même problématique lorsque le
président garandeau nous dit peut-être
dans un an peut être dans dix ans le
risque ou la charge n'apparaissent pas
réellement qualifiés ou de caractère
certain donc je voudrais que la tutelle
puisse nous dire l'analyse qu'elle fait
des provisions qui sont placés en
contrepartie de la trésorerie dont nous
avons vu qu'elle est significative sinon
sinon assez abondante et enfin est-ce
que la tutelle pourrait nous dire si
elle est en accord avec le propos que
nous avons entendu ça ne coûte rien au
budget de l'état est ce que vous
partagez cette cette vision des choses
donc monsieur culture monsieur budget
auriez vous la bonté de bien vouloir
vous exprimer et ensuite nous nous vous
avez trois pages de questions chez un
porteur spécial qui sont toutes
excellentes
merci monsieur le président en préalable
je voudrais rejoindre le constat du
président garandeau sur le fait que le
cnt était un instrument indispensable de
maintien de la diversité culturelle et
de maintien de la présence française sur
les écrans de notre pays mais aussi à
l'international en termes de diversité
et de présence culturelle
je vais me permettre de répondre assez
rapidement aux questions que vous posez
monsieur le président tout d'abord sur
la stratégie immobilière du cnc nous
avons été informés de la stratégie
d'acquisition du cnc portant sur
l'immeuble de la rue galilée
il faut savoir que nous sommes en ce
moment en discussion avec le cnc là
qu'on l'a rappelé sur un schéma
prévisionnel de stratégie immobilière
qui doit nous permettent normalement de
faire évoluer les implantations du
centre national du cinéma
c'est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
la stratégie de l'emprunt qui a été
adopté par le cnc n'est pas une mauvaise
stratégie
dans la mesure où premièrement cet
immeuble a fait l'objet d'une forte plus
value depuis le moment où il a été
acquis et où deuxièmement il s'avère
qu'actuellement l'ensemble des
implantations du cnc qui comprennent
aussi une implantation louer ne permet
pas une adéquation correct
d'installation des personnels du cnc qui
voyagent entre plusieurs immeubles qui
ne répondent pas aux normes actuelles de
france domaine qui 12 mètres carrés par
agent ce qui va probablement
nous amener dans les mois qui viennent à
réfléchir à une implantation plus
rationnelle du centre national du cinéma
cet emprunt n'est donc qu'une solution
transitoire qui a été pleinement
acceptée par les tutelles
deuxièmement sur la stratégie de
provisionnement du cnc vous l'avez
relevé un montant important de
provisions dont je relève qu'un certain
nombre d'entre elles sont fléchés sur un
certain nombre de risques identifiés le
premier nous le connaissons c'est un
risque immobilier et nous travaillons
dessus avec le cnc
le second porte sur un plan numérique
dont nous allons voir que l'écrêtement
que nous sommes en train de réaliser sur
les provisions constituées va sans doute
nous amener à procéder à son étalement
sachant que le cnc a réussi l'essentiel
je voudrais le rappeler dans les années
passées c'est à dire l'adaptation de
notre réseau de salles de cinéma à la
transition numérique qui est la garantie
du maintien d'une bonne fréquentation de
nos salles il suffit de regarder ce qui
s'est passé dans d'autres pays européens
ou extra européens pour constater que
c'est une des
recette des garanties vraiment
indispensable au maintien de la
prospérité du secteur cinématographique
français autres provisions celles qui
portent sur les avances du compte de
soutien qui sont si je puis dire transit
provisoirement dans les comptes du cnc
c'est peut-être là dessus qu'il ya un
travail à réaliser avec le cnc travail
qu'il a commencé à faire pour constater
qu éventuellement certain nombre de ses
provisions ne serait plus fondées mais
c'est un travail de longue haleine qui
réaliser année après année et qui doit
nous permettre de progresser afin de
déterminer ce qu'on appellerait le fonds
de roulement croisière du cnc dans une
circonstance où vous savez que la
conjoncture économique fluctue une
manière importante et j'en viens à un
point très important pour nous il nous
semble pas imaginable de déconnecter les
recettes du cnc du dynamisme ou du
moindre dynamisme du secteur
autrement dit
si on regarde les trois scénarios qui
sont envisagées par la cour et que je me
permets de reprendre un plafonnement des
dépenses du cnc s'ils pouvaient être
envisager éventuellement sur une partie
des dépenses qui ont été prises en
charge par le cnc pour un certain nombre
d'établissements publics qui participe
du rayonnement du cinéma comme la
cinémathèque comme la l'école de cinéma
la femis ne peut pas être envisagée pour
les dépenses du compte de soutien qui
répondent nécessairement à la dynamique
du secteur pour les dépenses sélectives
c'est une autre question et à mon avis
elle est beaucoup plus liée à la
question du suivi de la performance de
l'établissement et de la performance des
aides question qui a été soulevée par la
cour des comptes et sur laquelle le
président garandeau a commencé à
apporter des réponses en termes
d'adaptation et de rationalisation du
système dead on ne voulait pas arbitré
les dépenses ça c'est pas possible
nous ne souhaitons pas arbitré que je
souhaitais pas arbitré les dépenses ne
sont jamais bien pris non nous
souhaitons faire rire les défends je
perds mais il en est bien prêt à y
penser même souhaitons pas entre les
dépenses seraient bien très bien non
mais c'est clair il nous avons besoin
d'un peu de clarté dans un sujet
complexe
peut-être tombé à vitré les dépenses
automatique
nous avons bien compris
alors je pense que vous êtes y arriver à
peu près aux thermes
maintenant je me tourne vers le budget
pour qu'ils réagissent donc rapidement
cursive mans vous reprendrez la parole
au fur et à mesure de l'audition est ce
que vous partagez la proche de la
tutelle culture faites nous un peu
participé à vos à vos débats ça nous
intéressera on aura le sentiment d'être
dans la réalité pas dans la fiction
même si c'est une fiction française de
qualité dont nous sommes co producteur
monsieur le président si je comprends
bien vous préférez que je réagisse
directement aux questions précises que
vous posez plutôt qu'à l'ensemble du du
rapport dont je dis quand même en
quelques mots que qui partage le constat
qu'ont les constat qu'on peut faire y
compris en tant que tutelle sur les
évolutions qu'a connues le cnc les les
cinq dernières années y compris les
évolutions favorables en termes de
qualité de la gestion puisqu'il y en a
également
vous avez posé un certain nombre de
questions la première sur le projet
immobilier
alors tout d'abord sur l'opportunité de
cet achat comme la comme l'a dit mon
collègue de la culture il a été approuvé
son parent a parlé tutelle mais aussi
par par france domaine puisqu'il
semblerait je peux pas parler en leur
nom mais qui avait une opportunité
effectivement financière et immobilière
à acquérir mais votre question portait
plutôt sur l'opportunité d'un emprunt
alla alors je vais prendre la question
déjà autrement aujourd'hui ça ne serait
absolument plus possible au titre de
l'article 12 de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques
le cnc et en une administration publique
un organisme divers d'administration
centrale in une lui il serait plus
possible de s'endetter auprès d'un
établissement de crédit sauf pour des
motifs de trésorerie
bon néanmoins cette règle est est entrée
en application tout début 2011 donc
postérieurement à au projet dont il est
dont il est question connaîtrait que le
bon sens préexistait à cette loi qu'un
établissement qui a une trésorerie
langue et qui peut effectuer un portage
cours il peut se financer sur sa
trésorerie il n'a pas besoin d'aller
trouver la banque
alors si justement cette règle a été
mise en place qui est une nouvelle règle
de gouvernance des finances publiques
c'est que parfois on a besoin de règles
juridiques pour pour affirmer ce qui
effectivement on peut répondre du bon
sens je crois que la cour dans fait un
certain nombre de développements sur le
sujet donc peut-être qu'ils pourront ils
pourront vous éclairer mais je crois que
la cour des comptes souligne notamment
que les que le
que le contenir que la valeur des biens
immobiliers l'or l'or valeur potentielle
en cas de cession pourrait permettre à
elle seule de financer un nouveau projet
immobilier mais qui reste à définir
et par ailleurs il y à il ya une réserve
réserve immobilière donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un certain nombre de ressources
qui existent et en plus deux ans plus de
l'emprunt qui aurait pu être mobilisé
pour un projet immobilier
donc voilà sur ce premier point je crois
que la commission de la culture à une
échéance proche madame la présidente
peut être pourrions nous entendre si
j'ose dire
un couple d'intervention et à laquelle
répondre et nono nos amis d'en face et
les magistrats de la cour
donc madame la présidente
et monsieur le rapporteur spécial s'il
le veut bien
donc l'un à la suite de l'autre de tel
et puis ensuite le rapporteur général et
le rapporteur pour avis s'il est
toujours là il est parti
bon et bien ensuite le rapporteur
général relancera la la discussion si
vous le voulez bien madame la présidente
de la commission de la culture
merci monsieur le président d'être
attentif et notre expression et de tenir
compte de notre emploi du temps non
choisie qui nous oblige à une audition
très formalisé celle de la candidate à
la présidence de l'audiovisuel public à
un horaire que nous n'avons pas choisi
sur le sujet qui nous rassemble nous
avons eu de vifs débats au sénat lors de
l'élaboration du budget 2012 non pas
entre majorité et opposition mais entre
la commission des finances et les
membres de la commission de la culture
je ne pense pas qu'il faille nous
distinguer entre ceux qui parlent avec
leur coeur et ceux qui parlent garant de
la rigueur il y a une chose qui nous
rassemble et qu'il doit nous permettre
de trouver un consensus
c'est l'intérêt public dans cet intérêt
il y à la création la diversité des
oeuvres la santé d'une filière
internationalement reconnue et la bonne
gestion de l'argent public
mais ce n'est pas tellement de l'argent
public dont nous parlons au départ dans
cette bonne gestion il ya par exemple
indispensable soutien à la numérisation
chambre des collectivités le sénat par
sa commission culture est attaché à
cette mission du cnc d'appui à la
modernisation des salles de nos communes
et je sais que si quelques lenteurs dans
ces numérisations été repéré il y à des
phénomènes connexes
quand on entame un chantier il faut
rendre accessibles à toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap
ce sont des surcoûts qui quelquefois
font ralentir la motivation des communes
à pouvoir utiliser l'argent disponible
au cnc le cnc est suivi depuis 2010 un
an après les ordonnances de 2009
le sénateur la gauche jusqu'en 2011 puis
le sénateur et rapporteur leleu assume
cette tâche
nous avons lu avec attention le rapport
de la cour des comptes et nous sommes
monsieur le président sensibles à la
nécessité de clarifier le volet
immobilier avec des conventions claire
entre propriétaires utilisateurs et
autres utilisateurs comme la
cinémathèque par exemple nous sommes
sensibles aux besoins d'indicateurs de
suivi de stratégie et mama la
recommandation de cibler d'éventuels
écrêtement mais nous insistons sur la
modération indispensable des financiers
ce n'est pas parce qu'un secteur réussi
qu'il faut le fragiliser ce que le
rapporteur du cinéma leur sénateur
leleux dit avec ses propres mots entre
guillemets en france on a parfois le
génie de remettre en cause les modèles
qui marchent fermez les guillemets le
plafonnement des dépenses de soutien à
la création de soutien aux halles serait
contre productif
nous attirons également l'attention sur
le danger inhérent l'écrêtement qui
ampute une part du système mutualiste
il y a un vrai risque que les
contributeurs n'y trouvent des arguments
pour ne plus contribuer en conséquence
tout le monde serait perdant la
commission de la culture appelle donc à
la plus grande prudence
ne tuons pas un système vertueux en
revanche elle s'associe aux demandes de
meilleur suivi
je vous remercie monsieur le président
d'avoir modifié les ordres de parole
beaucoup madame la présidente de ce que
bono dit et je pense que votre
commission va rester représenté par l'un
de ses membres pour la suite de
l'audition pendant que vous allez passer
sur le gril votre candidate n'est ce pas
voilà c'est au moins une chose que peut
faire le parlement c'est satisfaisant
c'est bien alors monsieur le rapporteur
spécial aymeri de montesquiou
merci monsieur le président vous grands
bancs et culturel auquel nous sommes
conviés ce matin monsieur le président
le fas a mitonné les chiffres et le
président marié n'a pas pu résister elle
rejoint donc il me reste plus qu'à
démontrer un certain art d'aménager les
restes tout à l'heure tout à l'heure le
président garandeau on va parler de
l'affaissement de la fiction française à
la télévision mais je crois qu'il ya un
effondrement il y avait 56 mhz fiction
parmi les 100 meilleures audiences
c'est tombé à 3 donc c'est un
effondrement alarmant on peut très bien
comprendre le prosélytisme culturel
français qui est un support à notre
économie en général
le cnc participent
le cnc participe au financement de
nombreuses oeuvres où ces deux oeuvres
étranges et 120 métrage cent vingt longs
métrages par an avec 38 pays
c'est le plus haut ratio et on ne peut
que s'en réjouir
sauf qu'il ya un écueil c'est que ça ne
se passe pas en langue française donc je
ne vois pas quel est le support que ça
peut représenter pour notre langue ou
pour l'économie en général bien d'autres
plans qui allaient me suis penché il me
restait plus grand chose à dire
les commissions dead la cour a remarqué
que la gestion des ressources humaines
étaient globalement maîtrisé mais il ya
une augmentation de la masse salariale
et les commissions dead a de plus en
plus de collaborateurs et je m'interroge
n'existe pas n'existe-t-il pas un
conflit d'intérêt dans entre les
personnes qui participent à ces
commissions dette et leurs activités
professionnelles dans le cinéma
enfin une question qui se voudrait poser
au ministère pourquoi est-ce que le cnc
sort du plafond
qui était prévu par l'article 26 et
l'article 28 permet au cnc donc nous
sommes censés mais permet de prélever
150 millions sur les 800 millions c'est
est soulignée par le paysan marini mais
on ne veut pas que nous sommes plus à
une ère de théorisation et en
conséquence 150 millions ça me semble
assez peu je voudrais revenir très
brièvement sur l'aspect immobilier
aujourd'hui le cnc et nice et dans
quatre immeubles qui sont tous situés
dans le 16e arrondissement
on peut le croire mais le comprendre
c'est un arrondissement fort agréable
mais est ce que aujourd'hui dans le
cadre d'une rationalisation immobilière
est ce que on ne peut pas imaginer que
le cnc soient regroupées et extra muros
il y as certainement des lieux plaisant
ou peut-être l'inspiration viendrait
aussi bien au cnc que dans le 16e
arrondissement en quatre immeubles
plaine saint denis et un localisation
que le tour est la pression sera pas
pardonné jeu
est-ce que le rapporteur général
souhaite alors monsieur le président
messieurs les représentants des tutelles
messieurs les représentants de la cour
des comptes souhaitez-vous réagir à ce
qui a été dit ici par madame blandin
puis par monsieur de montesquiou si vous
permettez monsieur le président en
reprenant peut-être les sujets dans
l'ordre commencent à parler par
l'immobilier parce qu'il permettrait de
répondre aux précédentes interventions
quand j'en parle d'autant plus librement
que c'est mon prédécesseur qui avait
pris cette décision qui est une décision
vraiment excellentes puisque
l'acquisition de cet immeuble a permis
d'avoir une annuité d'emprunt inférieur
au coût de la location
donc en termes de gestion en bon père de
famille rien que pour ça c'était une
décision intéressante en plus la valeur
de cet immeuble a augmenté de 20% comme
ça a été rappelé par monsieur me en un
an
donc là aussi j'ai sur mon père de
famille c'était une excellente décision
prise effectivement comme ça a été
rappelé par en accord complet avec les
tutelles de quatre heures et une
deux comités financiers ou 7 ce sujet a
été validé par les tutelles et balleure
par ailleurs sur la trésorerie
c'est peut-être intéressant de le
préciser mais la trésorerie qui est lié
au compte de soutien
il faut bien voir que cette trésorerie
est dédié au compte de soutien et je
vais revenir dans un instant donc il
était inenvisageable de mobiliser une
partie de cette trésorerie dédiée au
soutien pour réaliser une opération
immobilière pour le centre alors sur
maintenant la question à venir le cnc a
été rappelé d'ailleurs aussi a
effectivement voulu lancer un appel à
propositions pour essayer de regrouper
l'ensemble de ses services dans un lieu
un lieu était trouvé une négociation
pouvait s'engager avec un propriétaire
malheureusement ce dossier a été bloquée
pendant six mois et nous attendons
toujours qu'ils soient débloqués donc
peut-être que nous serions en train de
déménager si nous avions eu l'accord de
france 2 m pour engager des discussions
sur ce bien en question nous avons dont
nous avons appris d'ailleurs hier qu'il
était désormais louer pour une
administration de l'état
concernant maintenant la numérisation et
l'état des réserves
la cour des comptes pour le site et ses
propres phrases mais vraiment c'est il
se trouve que j'étais directeur
juridique et financier en 2004 donc
j'avais reçu une première fois ce
rapport de la cour des comptes donc
l'approvisionnement de l'ensemble des
soutiens a vraiment été une décision
d'application du rapport des comptes du
rapport la cour des comptes de 2004 à
l'époque le cnc vivait selon une logique
de caisse et donc il profite de
provisionner rien et simplement ils
prévoyaient d'avoir une trésorerie qui
correspondent à ce qu'on appelle le
risque guichet c'est à dire que le cfc à
tout moment pourrait être en cessation
de paiement il suffisait que les
producteurs investissent davantage que
d'habitude
aujourd'hui cette sécurisation
exhaustive dans une logique
prudentielles c'est ce qui conduit à
immobiliser 500 millions d'euros
s'ajoutant à celle de fin 2011 500
millions d'euros au titre des
provisionnements des différences soutien
automatique se sont pour répondre à
votre question même j'ai pris l'exemple
extrême bien sûr un exploitant de salles
il a dix ans pour mobiliser son soutien
je rappelle que c'est de
l'investissement tout ça c'est à dire
que ce sont des travaux il peut le
mobiliser tout de suite il peut miser
dans dix ans les comportements des des
exploitants sont très difficiles après
déterminer
ça dépend de la taille de l'exploitant
de sa stratégie de mobilisation d'autres
mécanismes de financement dont il peut
avoir accès certains mobilise en masse
brutalement ça on ne voit pas ça
arrivait et d'autres le font de façon
beaucoup plus lisse et au fil du temps
mais on a complètement retenu l'idée de
la sécurisation maximale qui était une
encore une fois c'est est validée par la
cour des comptes et si ce qui aboutit à
ce provisionnement des 500 millions
d'euros ensuite vous avez des restes à
payer comme ça aussi c'est les dépenses
obligatoires etc seront certaines 50
millions d'euros en 2009 vous aviez déjà
550 millions d'euros de réserves
il est ensuite la réserve de solidarité
intergénérationnelle qui est destiné à
faire face à des mouvements de
conjoncture qui peuvent être très
violents dans l'inconnu en 2005 et en
2005 le cncf aurait pu être aussi là
aussi en cessation de paiement il a
fallu revoir les taux des différents
soutiens de manière extrêmement rapide
pour ne pas être en cessation de
paiement donc c'est très vert qui est de
57 millions d'euros elle a été
constituée au fil du temps il ya la
réserve immobilière effectivement qui
est lié au sujet dont on parle est ce à
dire que nous avons toujours dans cette
idée de de déménager et et même si nous
déménageons pas d'ailleurs il y aura des
travaux très importante de plus de 10
millions d'euros à réaliser sur place
plus l'acquisition d'un plateau
complémentaires pour justement ne plus
être locataire du quatrième immeuble
donc quand vous faites des erreurs qu
est ce qu il reste deux comme trésorerie
et bien il reste le plan numérique dont
on a parlé alors se pendre numérique ce
sont les salles les oeuvres sur les
salles il faut bien voir que si le cnt
n'avait pas investi une centaine de
millions d'euros sur cent millions par
an 100 millions jeu de temps on est
entre le plan des dépenses les combien
chaque année monsieur le président nous
serons la numérisation numérisés sur les